KILLED OFF.
RICHARD ROTH IS "OUTFRONT."
>> IT IS AN INDICATION OF TRUST.
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO KEEP
SECRETS FROM ONE ANOTHER.
>> BUT IT SEEMS THE ENTIRE
SEINFELD CAST KEPT A SECRET FROM
THE ACTRESS WHO PLAYED SUSAN
ROSS.
>> GEORGE CASTANZA'S FIANCE.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE ACTING WITH
HER.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A LILLY.
>> CAN I HELP YOU.
>> YES, WE WOULD LIKE SOME
WEDDING INVITATIONS.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU.
>> GEORGE, PLAYED BY JASON
ALEXANDER, WAS NEVER HAPPY ABOUT
MARRYING SUSAN AND NOW 17 YEARS
AFTER THE SHOW WENT OFF THE AIR
HE REVEALED TO HOWARD STERN HE
COULDN'T WORK WITH HER.
>> I COULDN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PLAY OFF OF HER.
>> YOU'RE BEING KIND.
>> NO, HER INSTINCTS FOR DOING A
SCENE WHERE THE COMEDY WAS AND
MINE WERE ALWAYS MISFIRING.
>> IT IS HARD TO TELL ON SCREEN
THERE WAS ANY PROBLEM.
>> I DON'T KNOW HONEY, WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO GET?
I WANT YOU TO GET ANYTHING YOU
WANT GET.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH, YOU WANT YOU
TO BE HAPPY.
>> HE SAID IN THE INTERVIEW,
HEIDI SWEATENBERG WAS A
WONDERFUL GIRL BUT HE GOT A CALL
FROM LARRY DAVID.
>> LARRY DAVID SAID GOOD NEWS, I
GOT A GRET ART FOR YOU THIS
SEASON, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
ENGAGED AND I SAID OH, GREAT.
WHO AM I GOING TO GET ENGAGED
TO.
AND HE SAID SUSAN.
AND I SAID WHO IS PLAYING
GEORGE.
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A DISASTER.
AND JULIA LOUISE-DREYFUS DIDN'T
LIKE HER EITHER.
>> AND JULIA SAID, DON'T YOU
JUST WANT TO KILL HER.
AND LARRY WENT BANG.
SO LARRY DECIDED TO KILL HER
OFF.
>> SHE'S -- GONE.
>> SUSAN IS GONE, BUT NOT HEIDI,
WHO IS NOW A FULL TIME MUSICIAN
IN L.A. TEACHING UKULELE
CLASSES.
NOT THAT THERE IS ANYTHING WRONG
WITH THAT.
SHE IS APOLOGIZING TODAY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA SAYING OH, DEAR
GOD, LEAVE HEIDI ALONE.
I'M SO MAD AT MYSELF FOR
RETELLING THIS STORY IN ANY WAY
THAT COULD DIMINISH